Dioro sticks his hand out to shake Net Laws's hand. And Net Laws
says, "I'm not shaking your hand. I don't like you." >> He's
like a bowling ball with legs. >> And so Dior Net Loss
takes the sunglasses off Dioro's face and puts them on and then
starts dancing away.
But there's another funny video apparently that we've missed
on the stream that we have to cover because I think Nick gets
Nick. Apparently this is about Nick getting bullied at VC bullied
at VidCon. Give it a second. >> So here's a funny story.
VidCon. Okay. VidCon. Turkey's rager at
>> Have you ever seen this? I've never seen this before.
I do think it's I've heard it's funny.
>> Am I on frozen? Cool.
Turkey Tom's rager at VidCon.
So Tom threw a big party in this skate
uh like this skate shop with this indoor like mini ramp and like
street session set. It was like a warehouse for a skateboard
brand. Okay.
And we're all there. So
the commentary people the commentary are people there.
>> oh. This isn't like a thing where Tom's found like two
sets of really cool friends and then Nicholas is just like the
totally mogged fat guy in the corner, right? Like Tom's got his
gun friends and he's got his [__] Jreg artistic like
Chad friendsaru
Jreg art Chad and then Brandon Herrera donut operator
Grandantham and then there's just a fat losser sitting in the
corner by himself. That's not going to be the story I hear, is
it?
>> oh, wait, no, he's got a he's got a >> Nicholas
Dioro shows up.
>> Okay. Nicholas Dioro shows up. So
Oi and Nicholas Dioro have beef. Oki's Weird Stories and Nicholas
Dioro have a have a public beef and they have for a long time.
So wait, who? Wait, who?
>> Oki and Nicholas Dioro. >> Oki.
The is Oi
have beef. Oi's Weird Stories and Nicholas Dioro have >> Who's
Oi? Oie.
Oki's Weird Stories. Oi's Weird Stories.
Uhoh. Uhoh. Got a Boruto fan here. We got a We got a Boruto fan.
Oh no. Oh no. We have to see a Nicholas Dioro right-wing pivot,
guys. Uh oh. So when I walk in, uh, Oki
and Dantavius
are pressing
Dioro because everyone they're all still friends with Boax
and I've like I've talked to Boax a few times. Nice guy. It's
totally criminal that look man
guy is in his mid20s when he wants to crossdress. Who gives a
Okay,
if Boax
wants to crossdress as an adult man, look, he's in the commentary
sphere. He's going to get dragged through the mud. Uh, and and
maybe he should have expected to get drugged through the mud
for his uh for his online behavior with the crossdressing,
but who cares? Who gives a Okay, I don't give a goddamn. Anyway,
you have the Oreo. Who is this? All the All this guy talks about
is this uh this >> Oh god, this guy's so Is this guy I
thought this guy wasn't Canadian. Is he
>> That was a hard about. That was a hard about right there.
That's a hard about. >> Other man and uh his his decisions
in his adult life.
Okay. Dirt bag.
>> Dirt bag. It's all he talks about. There's always streams
about his Boaxs and why Boax is a you know he's just making a
lull cit
right.
Oh no. So uh dude I I feel like the Tom circle must be really
interesting cuz I could just imagine if Tom invited the gun tubers
there. These guys are like, "Oh, so you got a problem with trans
people, eh? You got a problem with trans people? You got a problem
with trans people. You got a problem with me. Okay. You got a
problem with trans people, Nicholas Dioro? You got a problem
with me.
It's like the uh it's like a Broadway musical. Okay. They're
all lining up getting ready to fight, have a dance off or something.
Gun guys versus the artistic politics guys. Uh
>> what do you guys think about Palestine >> who
already doesn't like Dioro
presses Dioro? He goes up and he goes like, you know, uh Bob
is like really depressed.
Um how would you feel if like Boax killed himself? Like, you
know, you're basically like you're you're trying to get Bolex
to kill himself.
>> You're basically just uh you know, b like cyberbullying
this guy into like complete depression over like over nothing
like he didn't do anything to you. He's just existing on the
internet
and then net loss.
Does did any of them consider that Nicholas got an awesome pinball
machine out of this? That like Boax Bo's life was always going
to be finite. Okay. But a pinball machine that's forever.
>> Net loss walks up
and uh beefs Nicholas
So he he walks up. I I see this all. I didn't I wasn't I didn't
talk to Dioro. I walked up to him.
I walked up to Dioro
and then I was like realized who it was and I thought I don't
want to talk to this guy. I don't I don't even want to like instigate
uh with this dude. >> What the
dude? What the?
Bro, I don't even I I think this guy's disgusting. Just a total
loser. So much so I don't even want to talk to him. I don't want
to be near him. I don't want to This guy's face makes me sick.
>> So So
I walk up, realize that they're talking to Dioro, and then I
walk away.
Net loss walks up behind me >> and uh tells Dioro to his
face he doesn't like him
>> and Dioro's like
Dioro sticks his hand out to shake Net Laws's hand and Net Law
says I'm not shaking your hand. I don't like you.
And then takes Dioro's sunglasses off of his face. By the way,
look,
Dioro is a short fat. Okay,
>> Yurio is a short fat [__] He's like [laughter]
maybe and he's very big. >> He's like a bowling ball. He's
like a bowling ball with legs.
>> And so Dior net loss takes the sunglasses off Dioro's
face and puts them on and then starts dancing away
and and and dances and like Dioro goes to like chase him but
like can't chase him. So Nick just like has his sunglasses on
and dances away. Anyway, Dioro has told this story like
uh two or three times on stream and he keeps characterizing Net
Loss as like I'm sure people in the chat have seen Net Loss's
videos.
Um he keeps characterizing Net Loss as like a tiny
uh geeky guy and he's like, "Oh, this tiny guy this tiny guy
came came up to me. He was like, "You're Nicholas Dioro. I don't
like you." which is not what which is not what Net Law sounds
like at all. If you've seen his videos, he has like a deeper
voice than me. [laughter] >> I don't know about you, but
I had a pretty sick Christmas break. And I don't mean that in
the cool way. Okay, one could say that I amitable that you released
something new. New music is >> okay. Not the greatest outfit
to show >> Inospicious time. I still come to you nonetheless
at 2 a.m. upnetting my losses. Who else? I'll tell you why though.
Why? It's >> going to get this guy standing next to a door
frame. How tall is he?
I'm being told 6'2.
6'2 apparently. Okay. He totally height Mog Dioro very >> And
he's as tall as me. But we're both like 6 feet tall. So, just
the fact that like Dioro keeps telling this story
on his streams
and also is um you know characterizing net loss as some as like
a as a as an caricature that he's like not at all and anybody
who knows him or seen his videos can like clearly clearly disprove
any of the characterizations that uh
he's like a little nerdy. He's like a little it's not like he's
a he's not like a Chad.
He's like a little nerdy >> that Dioro has given net loss
is hilarious. And also every time Dioro has told this story,
every time Dioro has told this story, he says that he called
net loss a which he didn't do. He No, sorry. He said he said
I called him Idubbbz's favorite slur. So, I don't know if that's
the end or [clears throat] or
but he keeps saying that he called >> Bro, can you I'm
so glad that they've updated this on YouTube so you could just
say this. Okay. Net loss a slur, which he didn't like he didn't
call him a slur. He's like tells the story as if >> Oh,
he tries to like up himself. He tries to like he tries to like
big himself up. That's [__] up, man. Yeah. Yeah,
I just told this guy who's a [__] I just called this
guy a to his face cuz he stole my glasses and he like and he
like tried to like dance away like a weirdo. He's just total
nerd. Little nerd took my glasses >> like oh
this tiny guy walked up to me and was really geeky and annoying
and then I then I called him the I just
Is this the annoying Why would you lie about calling someone
a slur? Because he wants to be edgy because he's like oh I have
to be this is cool. This is my my perception of being cool
is uh yeah, he talked about this on the Halfbaked podcast. No,
it's really funny cuz his perception of >> Oh my god, do
we have that? Would we have that somewhere? The Halfbaked podcast
with the net loss like Nicholas describing this cuz I do feel
like that would really tie out the se that really tie off the
segment. It would be pretty awesome if we could find that him
telling his story. >> Being like this tough Long Island
dude who uh you know wears a Rolex
>> and uh and talks about um he's like my $600 sunglasses.
>> I bet I bet. >> Right. He's just his his perception
of being cool is just being this edgy Long Island dude who calls
people the
and in actuality he's a short fat who is bullying his old friends
into like
God. What a abhorent person, man. I don't know. It's so crazy
that
it's uh it's it's so crazy that you can uh
the slurs slinging larer.
It's too funny to not even have the balls to say the slur. I
know, man. Like, you're hanging out like Turkey is there. I don't
No one there gives a Half of them are commentary YouTubers. You
think if you say, you're going to get in trouble at the [__]
at the uh at the commentary party?
>> Anyway, funny as look, I feel like I feel like people
stay people say stay close to him because he's a demon because
I know he's friends with uh he's friends with like way Web Surf
and uh Tom and some of those other people and
I understand why you would want him why you wouldn't want him
as an enemy
uh because he will like unapologetically
uh you know double cross you any second he gets right. If >> No
way. What?
What? Huh?
>> It if it can become content, he will do it. And I feel
like you need to be in a position like like um >> it's
almost like when Becket says that like you don't react to Tommy
C doing this stuff cuz other YouTubers will look at it really
weird and it hurts Chud. It's like, okay, but you understand
the community and how you're viewed, right? You understand how
Nicholas is viewed by a whole bunch of other people.
Like, this is a random 150,000 sub YouTuber who talks to a bunch
of really influential people, by the way.
You know that this guy talks to JREG, he talks to Gokunaru. I've
seen them hanging out all the time. They talk to Tom. I've seen
Tom on their podcast.
You don't think having this opinion of Nicholas out there amongst
a bunch of YouTubers
means anything? I think it means a lot. Okay, hold on. Apparently,
I'm being told somewhere around here is where he starts talking
about this. >> I said and then I called him a slur. I'm
not going to say which
>> Hold on. Hold on. >> You know, you're saving you're
saving the internet one tell you about some other guy.
But that was extremely weird. >> Sweet. [laughter] >> So,
this was my like initial reaction. That party was nuts. I'm still
dying that Josh's friends rolled up. They left him at the Oh,
that was the other thing. I asked him, "Where is Josh right now?"
Cuz all his friends went to Tom's rager without him. He was back
at the hotel room. I'm the I'm the bad guy. They didn't even
drag him out to the party. I don't even know if he if he could
have got an invite. Were these like his close I don't think these
guys are Boax's close friends.
I Oh, I do. You see how he frames? Oh, they're all Bowser's friends.
What if they just saw some [__] that was going down?
They think you're a loser.
Way more obvious. Way more way more obvious explanation, man.
They just think you're a loser. They're not super close to Boax.
They might have talked to Boax. Maybe Boax went to VidCon, hung
out with some people, told them, "Hey, you're like a real prick
and and this guy made fun of me. Maybe hung out with some more
leftyleaning people, right? This guy's a real He's a total [__]
prick." I got linked another another clip here as well. Just
give me a second. What is this one? Is this him telling it again?
Dude, the the update for that one is really I mean we talked
about this. I don't know if we talked about it on the
>> Okay, hold on. This one's before this. This one's before.
>> We'll do this around that time. >> Said no or
whatever. It had nothing to do with me, but they left Dude, they
left their friend at the hotel room and they came to judge me
about it. Was extremely weird and I wish that was the only weird
thing that happened. Uh, briefly, I have to tell you about some
other guy. And again, I have to meal him too. I I don't know
who this is. >> Nicholas, the goat >> because right
after this, I was wired. This was weird. I I walked back to Wavy.
I'm talking to Wavy. Uh, and then this guy comes up to me and
I'm using this to describe him because it's how he like sounded
like this is how his voice sounded. So, I had heard little back.
>> It's almost It's almost like there's just, you know,
bunch of random creators who don't like this guy.
I was just like wired. I was so thrown off. Why wouldn't people
like me? Why would Why would people just like not like me? Are
there like people talking about me behind my back? Why would
people just like not like me? I'm so >> Little backtrack
right here. Little backtrack here. Uh, I had heard that there
was a political streamer at the Canadian political house party
who walked up to my friends, I guess, and said that like Nick
Dioro gives Nicks a bad name. It was like, I'm out here protecting
the Nick's legacy or something. This is a political streamer
whose name is Nick. I really apologize. I don't know any more
than that. It's a guy named Nick who apparently gives Nick a
good name while Nick
>> Oh, this is the the net guy. This would be the net guy,
right? Because because I believe that
Art Chad just called him Nick when Art Chad referred to this
guy in the conversation like in this context of him telling the
story and said this guy's name was Nick. Okay, so we're going
back to the
should we I'm going to keep going >> and Nick Dioro are
like destroying the the the sanctity of the Knicks. They have
the curse, right? The curse. So apparently I I I I couldn't believe
this was funny that somebody like went on a tangent about me
at a party to my friends, but I I don't know. I was I thought
it would be disarming. I eventually they go, "Nick, that's the
guy." So right after all this stuff with the Josh friends happened,
I walked up and I shook this guy's hand and I don't know. I I
was [__] up. I tried to say like, "Hey, look, I'm
the Nick that you seem to be protecting the the name of Nicks
from or something." He goes, "What?" I go, "You know, I'm the
Nick that you're like trying to, you know, you're saving you're
saving the internet one Nick at a time or something." I forgot
what I said to him, but it was totally normal. It wasn't like
uh whatever. And he go he looks me in the eyes and he goes, "You're
Nick Dioro." And I'm like, "Um, yeah."
[laughter] And he goes, "I'm not shaking your hand."
It's like, "Oh, okay." Which is fine. You don't have to shake
my hand. That's cool. But then after that, he gets in my face
and he's like, "Oh, I love that. This is just another perfect
indication." Hold on.
The tone indicators always fake. Always fake because he doesn't
have a he doesn't have anything good to say for himself and how
he handles the situation. He's the fat loser who waddles after
the guy who steals his glasses and then realizes I'm too slow.
I could never catch him. And that's not really the case. So instead
of like instead of trying to warp the story around like I told
this guy to give me my glass, he's just like this guy. This guy
came up to me was like, I'm not even shaking your hand. I'm not
even going to shake your hand.
>> Wow. I don't like you. [laughter] It reminds me of when
Allan was shooting the guy with the water gun. So, so he's like
in my face like like within like a centimeter of my face,
right? And uh and the only reason I'm telling this story is because
of how it ends. So, he goes and he like he like he's I'm like,
[laughter] "What the are you going to do about it?" Right? Like
he's in my in my face. And then he's like I forgot what he said.
And then I called him a slur. I'm not going to say which slur,
but it's Idubbbz's favorite slur. I'm like, you're acting like
kind of, you know, blank right now. I called him a slur because
it was like really weird that he was in my face. So he snatches
my Ray-B
off my head. He He starts dancing aggressively at me. That's
the only way I can describe it. He He started like Westside storying
me. So I followed him for like two >> That is what I That
is what I imagined. He's painting the correct picture and I realized
he's not going to stop dancing. So I just walked back over to
the group or whatever. We just started laughing at it. It was
extremely It was extremely awkward encounter too. I don't I don't
know what to [laughter] So I waddled back over to the group and
we started laughing at everybody else and not me for getting
my glasses stolen by the 6' tall like gigachad. That definitely
not definitely not. I guys we went and we all laughed at those
dudes who stole my glasses and said I'm a piece of [__]
We just laughed at those
Yeah. I I called this guy. You're a real You're a real man. Uhhuh.
Uh-huh. Uh-huh. [laughter] He just started like aggressively
dancing. Um, and then he walks over and he goes, "Oh, these are
prescription. I'll give them back." And I'm like, "Thanks, dude."
Yeah, that was awesome. I never shot back again. That was a That
was a side quest. That was He just started trying to mate with
me like live in the room. I don't know. [laughter] Maybe because
of the slur, he's like, "I'm going to just start dancing at him,
dude. He just started breaking He just started breaking down,
dude. It was [laughter] I That was [__] That was
actually insane. Holy."
Um, look on Discord, Smaggle. I looked on Discord. I'm not seeing
anything here.
All right. I have multiple apparently he stole the story multiple
times. We got to we got to tell the story a h 100 different times,
guys. So, there's this one with Halfbaked, which is funny cuz
this is I think I've seen this one. I think I've seen the art
for this one. Okay. But we also have this one from Halfbaked.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Where did I just put it?
What did I just do with the clip? Right here. So, this one was
7 months ago, July 5th. July 4th, rather. This one is seven months
ago. June 30th. So he told this one and then he went on half
baked. He told the story again. >> Taking sips and pouring
vodka into the White Claws and high noons and why go wasted,
bro. >> That's what they were saying in the chat when I
said, "Yeah, I was blasted dude. I was high drunk. I was having
a great time floating around the party." All right. And I So
I'm standing kind of in the corner or whatever. And all of a
sudden, Ghost Gum comes up to me and starts talking to me about
Josh and goes, "Hey man, I hear Josh is coming. What are you
going to do?" And I'm like, "Oh, really? They finally invited
him to something?" And he was like genuinely surprised, right,
that this like that I didn't like go, "Oh no, Josh is coming."
I I told him what I told you. I've been I've been telling people
to invite him to everything for the entire weekend. I have not
stopped this guy or black balled him in any way. I've not hindered
his vacation. And before I know it, all three of them are surrounding
me in the corner. So ghost comes. So now, hold on. Now it's gone
from one guy came up to him, wouldn't shake his hand. Another
guy came up and took his glasses or something. Now it's Well,
actually, I'm surrounded in the corner. I'm actually surrounded
by these guys.
Interesting how the story evolves over >> Right there.
Oak's in the middle. And I think it's Dantavius, the bearded
man on the right. And I'm like, "Huh? What's happening right
now?" So, I'm up. I'm If I don't give a perfect rendition of
what they said, I apologize. But it starts off normal, and they're
like, "Dude, you got to let give Boaxs a break. Why are you still
going after Bo Blacks?" And I'm like, well, he tried to get me
into a fight with technicals, which could have harmed my my if
I got locked into that, I could have like not been making regular
content that could harm me financially or whatever, uh, by like
lying about this comment cop. He got me like fight with all these
different people from my past all at once or whatever. Uh, it
went really well, but if it didn't, that could have been a huge
inconvenience on me. So, like obviously I'm going to more, right?
>> And then, uh, I feel like Nick's, how do I put this?
There's another projection happening here with Chud
where a lot of people make it about finances in a way that's
like um kind of disingenuous. I don't know. I think a lot of
people do look at this as like the finances will be downstream
of doing good content and act
And Nick sees the finances like he's going to act in a way that
protects the finances. And while I say everybody has the finances
in mind,
I think Nick's like way more objectively about the
and maintaining that at any cost. It seems really transparent
to me and like
I'm not sure I have the the biggest. I'm not like totally against
that cuz it is your job and it's not something you should ignore,
but I do feel like he'll justify just totally destroying people
because well, they're going to say something mean about me. they're
going to say something bad about me and they just had to die.
They had to like be totally wiped off the internet. Like it's
a total existential crisis when Boax wants to talk some or I
don't know. I don't know what the technicals thing is all the
way. So,
it's kind of interesting. But I will say when I heard about you
know Boax trying to start sorry Nicholas trying to talk about
Boaxs in DMs. Oh, there was a whole wait there was a whole other
VC. I wonder if I ever recorded this. There was a whole other
VC where like Destiny joined at one point late at night and it
was like me, August, Destiny, Nicholas and and Nicholas was reading
off every bad thing like his entire history of Boax versus Destiny.
He was telling Destiny about every time Bob has ever been mad
about Destiny, been picked at Destiny. I forgot that
Oh man, that's really funny. like me, August, Destiny,
Queman might have been there. I don't know if Quimman was there
to be honest with you,
but he he went through like every single like the whole riot
act. And it's funny cuz August was asking these questions at
first and then Destiny joined and then I think I think
I can't remember if
Oh, did I suggest it or did August suggest it?
But it was like, "Oh, do you think like Desi would get a kick
out of this?" I can't remember if it was me or him. And so Destiny
joined and Nick went through the whole thing again with Destiny,
just like letting Destiny know all the [__] all the
weird Boax had ever said about him. All the times Bob was mad
at him, when Boax said he wasn't mad at him, and like when actually
Bob was lying about
Yeah, I remember that. You don't remember that cuz this happened
off stream. This 100% just happened off stream. But then I think
the next day or maybe two days later, Destiny like started talking
about stuff he'd heard from that conversation on his stream.
>> Fun fact. Um I obviously don't have like moral condemnation
for it. I'm just leaking it because it's funny.
You know, Nick always says, "I don't even know Destiny. I've
never talked to I don't really talk to Destiny." It's like, "No,
you talked to him a lot about Boaxs that night." Definitely.
>> They start like progressively getting weirder about
it until Oki. >> Oh, I leaked this before. Oh well,
>> It was a random thing that happened. >> Just who
I had a normal interaction with prior than the same day where
he's like, "Oh, dude, we should box." Remember we went boxing?
Same day, normal interaction when he was >> This was before
that. Trust me, this was way before that. >> Then he goes,
"You're just you're like a bully." I don't know if he said bully,
but he's like, "You're on a power trip, man. You have no power
in your real life, okay? and you take it out on bow black so
you can feel powerful for once in your miserable life or something.
And I'm just like >> I mean that's true. That's obviously
true. Yeah, there is something of a power fantasy there. That's
that is
there is no cabal. I'M THE CABAL. THAT'S WHAT THAT IS. OKAY.
That's the same thing when he goes after Bobs. What cabal? What
do you mean when you say the cabal? You mean me. I'M THE CABAL.
THAT'S Nicholas in a nutshell. Okay. Like whoa. What are [laughter]
you talking about? You sound [__] crazy. >> True.
Snooch. >> What's going on right now? And And now at this
point, Ghostgum kind of turns off and looks Dude, Bo Black is
kind of Bag
uh Ghost Gum turns off and starts talking to somebody else. So
now it's really just the two of them talking to me. And then
all of a sudden, like, you know, they they're like going, "Oh,
I tried to help Bo Blacks. We're trying to get him in a good
direction and something." And I go, "Well, let me stop you right
there. I've been giving this guy advice for years. Now you're
in my shoes. Can you tell me if he's listening?" And then one
of them goes, "Ah, you got me there, Nick." Or something like
that. And I'm like, "Listen, I'm not trying to this guy over.
I thought this was like a salvageable situation." And then all
of a sudden he goes, "How would you feel if he killed himself,
Nick?" And I'm like, "What?"
That's again total lie. Didn't think it was a salvageable situation,
which is why he was telling Queman and me all of the dirt on
this guy. Okay. All of the dirt. And then and then Queen gets
called into that Chud call with Bo Blacks there and Nicholas
is like, "Oh my god, I had no idea any of this would happen."
Oh my god. I have no idea. I had no idea. I didn't know. How
would Queen want to call in? How would any of this Oh my god.
Bolex. No. Bolex. No.
I didn't even think about all this.
Huh.
Very interesting.
>> THAT ESCALATED.
>> SO, I'm just staring at this guy like like with a smile.
I'm like, is there going to be a punchline at the end of this
joke? Like, what's happening right now? Is this Oi talking to
you or the >> No, this is the Dantavius beard guy. He's
like, "How would you feel if he killed himself?" [laughter] >> And
eventually I'm I'm just sitting here. It's just registering this
is happening to me right now. This is the most awkward encounter
of my entire life. And I just start laughing and I go like I'm
I'm as advertised. What the would I care if Josh dies? What What
does that have to do with me? What do we We're at VidCon having
drinks. What are you doing? This is weird. So they start like
going
and I go, "All right, hold on." So, I put my hand on Oi's shoulder
and I I split the two of them and I walk through him and I go,
"Maybe next time, you know, have your friend come and fight his
own battles cuz this is really pathetic." But, uh, yeah, I feel
like I got baited by proxy. But, they actually admitted that
they left him at the hotel to come to Tom's party. Like, what
kind of friends are you? >> Why are they leaving? >> Because
he I guess he he either didn't want to go or
>> kind of keep feeding the the whole line about Boax not
being invited.
I'm guessing they did invite him. Like when he first tells the
story, Boax was invited. People were expecting Boax to come.
Right. It sounds like maybe Boax didn't want to go. It doesn't
sound like Boax didn't have an invite. Sure sounds like he was
invited when Nick first tells the story. Right. Right. Like,
oh, Bo is going to be here. Wait, is it this time? At one of
these points when he's telling the story, he literally says,
"Oh, somebody told me Boax was going to be there." Well, it sounds
like he was invited. No,
he wasn't invited. Uh, so they're all So on the big last night
party of VidCon, he sat in his hotel room alone, I guess. >> Oh,
that's sad. >> Because his friends went to go party without
him and then [clears throat] they came over. >> Was it
Was it in this one or the previous one? Now I have to Now I have
to go find it. Hold on. Backs. Well, that uh hold on. Here we
go. Bobs. Uh,
no. No, no, no, no. It's um Oh, no. Josh is coming. There we
go. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It's in this one. It's right here about
Josh and goes, "Hey man, I hear Josh is coming. What are you
gonna do?" And I'm like, "Oh, really? They finally invited him
to something?" And he was like genuinely surprised, right, that
this like that I didn't like go, "Oh, no. They genuinely invited
him to
What kind of friends are you? >> Why are they leaving?"
>> Because he I guess he he either didn't want to go or
he wasn't invited. Uh so there so on the big >> Well, you
kind of know which one it is. It's just little little things
where he just like makes somebody, you know, little little edges
here and there. Little edges here and there. Last night party
of VidCon, he sat in his hotel room alone, I guess. >> Oh,
that's sad. >> Because his friends went to go party without
him and then they came over and blamed me, which is funny cuz
I didn't try to keep him out. >> Here's my assessment of
this. This is all Tom's fault. >> It probably is in some
way, to be >> Tom, why didn't you invite Bobby, >> Well,
he unfollowed me on Twitter over the over the weekend, so I assume
that he fell. Oh, well then yeah, you can't invite somebody unfollows
you. Yeah, you're right. >> I know. Yeah, he felt jipped
by me. He broke the mutual. >> Did you ever find out who
the Canadian Nick was? Like the Canadian Nick guy? >> Yeah,
he's I know him. >> Do you know who he is? >> You
were mesmerized by his dancing. >> Dude, immediately after
this, I was fum I was fuming that that had just happened. But
immediately after this, I go meet back up with Wavy and we're
standing there talking and then all of a sudden he goes, "Dude,
that's the guy." Apparently at the Canadian party the day before,
some guy was walking around saying like, "Oh, my name's Nick.
I do politics, but I'm a good Nick. You know, there's a lot of
bad Nicks out there giving us Nick's a bad name. Like Nick Fuentes
and Nick Dioro, those guys awful. I'm a good Nick. True. >> So,
he didn't realize he told like all my friends that at the party.
I guess he didn't [laughter] know we interacted. >> Same
club. >> So, I walked up to him and I introduced myself.
I go, I'm the bad Nick that you're saving everybody from. And
he goes, "What?" I go, "You know, you're saving all these Nicks
out." >> I introduced myself. I walked up to him and introduced
myself >> there. I'm the one that you're saving them from
or something. And he goes, "Oh, I'm not shaking your hand." >> He
owned.
>> And then he No, but then he gets right in my face and
he goes, "I don't like you." And it sounded like the red guy
from Smiling Friends. And I just started >> This did not
happen. >> Now I totally understand why Art Chad felt like
he had to come out and say something about this. Yeah. This on
the 12th. The halfbaked episode. This one is on the 4th.
Now I understand.
Oh boy. Man, >> I don't This is I don't remember this.
>> No, I There were witnesses. Ask Wavy. there are witnesses.
He's like, "I don't like you." And I'm like, "Oh, [laughter]
okay." I'm like, "So, wait, what are you going to do about it?"
And he's like, and then [laughter] I just called him a slur.
I'm like, "You're acting like a slur right now."
So, he snatched my glasses off my face and started dancing seductively
at me. So, I followed him for like two seconds and I realized
he's not turning around [screaming] and then I walked back. >> It
all connects. >> He started aggressively dancing at me.
I've never seen. So, Dude, it was like
>> Dude, Tom is kind of ripping him. Tom kind of knows,
man. Tom kind of knows that. Hey, you got you got totally apparently
you tried to chase him and while he was dancing towards you,
he like backed away.
I don't know. Maybe he maybe he put the glasses on. Realized
he couldn't realize the guy, you know, these might be expensive.
I'll give him
Poor decision, man. Side story. It was the weirdest I've ever
seen. I thought I was in a musical.
>> I literally thought I was in a musical. I It was the
most confusing thing I've ever seen. Dude, what would you do
if somebody starts flamboyantly dancing aggressively towards
you, Tom? What would you do in that situation? >> I don't
I don't know. I don't know. >> It was the weirdest. You
know who this person is, dude? Cuz I I've said this story on
stream and they still can't ID like but they they still don't
know who this YouTuber is. Is this a streamer or a YouTuber?
>> He's a YouTube guy. >> I just know him as the
flamboyant Nick from politics or something. Dude, I literally
was just like, I don't do I what do I do here? >> Vega,
what would you do if somebody stole your glasses and then seductively
ass [laughter] in front of you? >> I just called him a
slur to his face and I punched him after. I feel like it's a
hate crime. >> What happened before him talking or I'm
not going to shake your hand? Which is fair enough. I do that
to people. I say, "I don't like you, bro. I'm not going to shake
your hand." >> And he comes back over and he goes, "Oh,
they're prescription. You can have them back." I'm like, "Thanks
for my $600 glasses." Yeah, but if he went if he went to go like
take my glasses or he did, then he's just going to get smacked,
bro. That's not my fault. >> Yeah, this uh Vega Vega and
Nick are like the same guy basically. Vega and Nick, they're
they're like the be they're like the same guy, right?
Nick Nick was totally ready to hit this guy. He just didn't want
to do it, man. I What is he? Come on. Nick didn't want to get
violent.
Nick's a real force. When When Nick gets some momentum behind
him, all right,
he can't be stopped. Inertia is his strongest weapon. >> Oh,
it is your fault. >> You got to understand, I'm in like
an aura right now. Like the Bob
baiting just happened and then that happened. >> Oh, they
happened back to back. >> It was back to I was fuming over
that. That's why I was so mad and I got and then all of a sudden
that happens and I'm like, dude, we went the whole weekend and
there was just and then all of a sudden this just goes down.
That's crazy. Uh, but otherwise it was fantastic. I have no other.
>> Wait, that's what I'm saying. I know Vega is a big tough
guy. I know Vega could actually do something. That's the whole
point. I've seen how they draw Vega in all these things, right?
I don't think Vega is here. Actually, I don't think Vega's Avatar
is here, but I've seen how they draw Vega.
Um, he's like a big like Jack guy, right? Big scary Boruto fan,
you know?
I get it. I get it.
He's the black one. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Okay. So, I've seen
I've seen his like avatar. I assume it's somewhat accurate. He
looks like a guy who could actually do something. Okay. He's
not actually black. All right. Fair enough. Anyway. Okay. We've
got one more instance of him wreak this him. This is him right
here. This is the guy. We got one more instance on the episode
with Willy Mack. Okay.
One more instance. Apparently, this is another instance of him
talking about >> We probably did. Obviously, Bob's never
really recovered the entire year. Uh 111 will go down as one
of the most disgusting days in commentary history. I think many
[laughter] many Yeah. One many a man has has traversed onto their
Twitter timeline that night and found something that they can
never unsee. And since then, Boax has kind of looped for a while.
I think the big update for that is when his friends cornered
me at Turkey's rager party at VidCon and asked me what I would
do if he killed himself. >> that was still one of the that
was one of the craziest things that's ever happened cuz again
I spent the whole week I guess hanging out with technicals and
Tom could attest to that. Like I think Technicals drove me to
have dinner where we sat next to Technicals and obviously everyone
knows that I have like had tons of beef with him in the past
and stuff. That was totally normal. And it was Bo Blacks that
was like the big weekender, right? And I still remember this.
I can never unremember the way that this went down like cuz they
asked me they're like, "What would you do if he killed himself?"
And I just started laughing cuz that's like an insane thing to
say to somebody. But what they didn't know and what I knew at
that exact moment is that I had actually scheduled all my videos
in advance and I had put two videos per day and this was the
last day of the trip. There was nothing I could sub around. So
no matter what happened the next day I had a 12hour Boax retrospective
locked and loaded to drop and I hadn't covered him in months.
I was like oh this will be a fun treat for people not knowing
that any of this was going to happen. So as soon as
Bro, am I the only I have Dude,
I
I feel like
he might have had it in the back pocket.
What What are the odds do you think that Nick had like started
making it, realized it was gratuitous, didn't want to do it,
and then he had those guys confront him and steal his glasses,
and he's like, "I'll show them. I'll [__] You want
to steal my glasses? You want to steal my glasses and try to
humiliate me in front of my friends? You want to steal my glasses?
I'll show you. Boom. I'm starting on Bolex again. I
>> as I leave, it's like a dead man's hand switch activated.
And if a 12hour and and out of all the compilation videos I did,
that one performed the best. >> The I couldn't >> totally
planned that any I didn't plan I couldn't have planned it better
even if I had foresight to know it was going to >> Yeah.
He um he was walking up to people at that. Do Tom, do you remember
some of the like the footage of people like filming him like
Bigfoot around the convention center? >> Remember remember
what a loser Boax is though, guys? >> Yeah, I remember
a few people sent that to me uh at some point. I just kind of
didn't say anything about that, but I do remember that happening.
Yeah, >> he got fed food like grapes or something by some
weird YouTuber who went on a bridge and and said he was going
to kill himself or something the next day. Do you remember this?
>> Yeah, that was kind of fascinating. Yeah. Um, [laughter]
well, I don't know. I don't know if he made the Boby video cuz
it sounds like if it's a 12-h hour retrospective.
It sounds like he would have had it uploaded to his channel,
right? And maybe he'd re I don't know. I don't believe he could
have gone and made a 12-hour video that dropped like that weekend
or like the next day. We'll see. >> I hope that uh, you
know, I wish I I wish Is it still him? I wish him the >> Oh,
that's a good question. >> I wish him the best. Is he posting?
>> I wish he gets a Manscape sponsorship. Oh, I looked
up Bolex and the latest video is internet anarchist. 1.4 million
views. Oh my god. [laughter] >> Oh my god. >> Wait,
he made a video on Bolex and he got 1.4. That's crazy. >> dude.
You have no idea, dude. Bolex is a is a money-making machine
for everyone but Boax. >> This is your fault, Nick. This
is your >> Boax should not have gone completely crazy.
No, you know whose fault this is? We found out on this podcast.
That was another update. It's Auggie's fault. >> Oh, it
is Aug. Well, we'll get to that episode. to talk him down. Yeah.
And Tom wasn't even >> that came out this year. Augie.
>> All Auggie's fault. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. So, this
is the video. I assume this is the video. So, when's VidCon 2025?
VidCon 2025
was the 19th to 21st. So, it would have had to be that Nicholas
got home the next day after it ended
and edited this video together and then put it out. So, I don't
know how much there is in this
I'm guessing he had this edited together. Okay. I I'm guessing
I'm Come on. There's no way he could edit this together on time,
right?
There's no way. I don't think so. You link it. I can link it.
Yeah.
Yeah, I can link it. I could do that.
I didn't feel like any of the Bubble Black stuff was like that
crazy. I don't think I I feel like I didn't have like the strongest
of opinions on it
until
the Mr. the Mr. Misman thing. Okay, that was where it jumped
the shark and I'm like, "Okay, I have to make fun of this guy
now." I'm sorry.
Now I have to make fun of this guy.
Now it is funny.
Come on.
It is It is actually funny now a little bit. A little a little
bit. Right.
Uh that time Aiden leaked that dude
Aiden be leaking a lot on this guy. >> That there was a
line out the door and it turns out Dioro and all them couldn't
even get in. They couldn't even get in. They waited in line for
like 40 minutes and they couldn't even get in and at some point
people were just getting added to the waiting list and the bouncer
was just asking to see people's sub count to let them in. Dior
did not get in. Um and then I ended up meeting him for the first
time later that night. Why'd you add the pisco thing at the end?
Come on, man.
That is kind of funny. But
that's that also I'll be real that also sounds like the gayest
thing ever. Checking sub counts at the door, bro. Come on, man.